s'agissant des états unis y plaire tel
un enfant l'interrogé sur les
gratte-ciel qui sortaient de terre et le
travail à la chaîne dont on parlait de
plus en plus en allemagne
les deux volumes de mein kampf est créée
en 1924 et 1925 témoigne pourtant d'une
connaissance fine de la politique
américaine
quelqu'un a bien dû apprendre des choses
à hitler dans ses mémoires cousy ne
cache pas qu'il tenta à plusieurs
reprises de convaincre le führer qu'une
alliance entre les deux pays n'étaient
pas inenvisageable et qu'il fallait
maintenir de bonnes relations avec les
états unis
quand il lu mein kampf et plus encore le
second volume
il pensa d'abord qu'il avait gagné la
bataille
sa bataille l'amérique était partout
moelleux ce qui m'intéresse aussi dans
le personnage de poux dit c'est
précisément à travers lui de raconter
une autre histoire de l'amérique une
histoire de l'amérique qui est pas
forcément celle de la liberté de la
démocratie de celle qui vient nous
libérer de la barbarie mais d'une
amérique qui à un moment donné à tanguer
et qui a regardé l'allemagne nazie avec
avec des yeux peut-être pas de l'amour
mais avec d'un intérêt certain
[Musique]
il était de père allemand de munich et
de mère américaine d'origine allemand
mais des maires américains du coup ils
avaient la double nationalité et le fait
d'être à la fois et américains et
allemands a conditionné sa vie le
mystère c'est d'aller comprendre qui est
cet homme qui a été c'est le cas le
confident d'hitler le plus proche
d'hitler hitler quand il sort de prison
en décembre 1924 il va chez pouzy
directement il lui a joué du piano du
wagner il la régénérer ils ont été
pendant quelques années
vraiment extraordinairement proche
comment cet homme s'est retrouvé ensuite
à être l'informateur oddo roosevelt
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale puis
reparti dans sa maison à munich dans
laquelle il est mort et dans laquelle
elle est hitler dans les années 20 il
fait partie tous ces personnages qui ont
été un moment donné hyper important tous
les journalistes qui voulaient voir
hitler se demander où était pouzy ou
untangled je veux voir ernest nfor
gueule son vrai nom je veux voir plus
dit il a été un moment donné au coeur du
monde est il arrivé à un moment donné
que son destin à l ess accomplir son
destin c'était de marquer la grande
histoire de faire un pont entre deux
mondes entre l'allemagne nazie qu'il a
aimée qui a défendu qu'il a promu y
compris à harvard en 1934 où il se rend
pour les 25 ans de sa promotion il a
invité harvard lui le nazi invité en
grande pompe il il a voulu justement
dresser un pont entre ces deux mondes le
monde de son père helmand de sa mère sa
propre identité d'être à la fois
allemands et américains il a tenté d'en
faire le destin du monde
en ralliant les deux pays l'amérique
démocratique et l'allemagne nazie contre
un ennemi commun qui étaient les
bolchéviques les communistes les les
soviétiques l'urss ne se rappelle le
judéo bolchevisme à la fois juif et
bolchévique c'était l'ennemi commun et
il a pu croire y parvenir à plusieurs
moments parce que ce que je raconte dans
le livre est ce que c'est aussi ce que
ce roman permet de raconter c'est à quel
point les états unis des années 20 et
surtout des années 30 on était perméable
à l'idéologie fasciste
il ya des images moi ce qui m'a donné
envie d'écrire ce livre c'est
les photos que j'ai découverte des
années 30 qui sont assez connus où on
voit le madison square garden à new york
pleins à ras bord de militants nazis
avec des croix gammées partout on est au
coeur des états unis à new york dans les
années 30 et jusqu'en 1939 on a ces
images-là à new york dans la presse
américaine les premières années
d'arriver au pouvoir de roosevelt
hitler est perçue plutôt favorablement
comme quelqu'un qui est volontaire et
autoritaire et qui réutilise les moyens
de l'état pour relancer l'économie
ce que veut faire aussi roosevelt avec
le new deal mais d'un autre côté ce qui
est vraiment fascinant c'est de voir
comment l'allemagne nazie a regardé les
états unis avec fascination
ça a été hitler qui avait le portrait
d'henry ford dans son bureau dans les
années 20 ça a été quand il a fallu
établir les lois de nuremberg en 1935
c'est les lois qui définissent ce qui
est un juif et surtout comment se
prémunir de l'influencé juive sur
l'allemagne aryenne et bien les juristes
allemands ont puisé dans les lois de
série gassion raciale américaine un
modèle dans les états unis des années 30
il y a un vrai courant fasciste il y a
des gens qui défendent un suprémaciste
blanc qui défendent des idées fascistes
qui défendent l'idée que les ennemis
sont en dehors du pays et qu'il faut
absolument protéger la race américaine
et forcément quand on écoute certains
des discours de donald trump canton
disque écoute surtout certains de ses
partisans
on ne peut que se dire que le discours
d'un trump aujourd'hui même si je ne dis
pas moi que trump et fasciste il
s'inscrit dans une histoire américaine